(light bouncy electronic music)
- That's cute.
(doorbell rings)
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Hi!
- Hi, package for Mila?
- [Milo] It's Milo, but yes.
Alright, not that hard a name.
- Have a nice day.
- Where's that guy from?
- Did your mom send cookies?
- Yeah, amongst some other things.
- Yay.
- She's supposed to be
giving me a necklace that
I've had my eye on for Kwanzaa.
- [Man] You guys give gifts for Kwanzaa?
- We try to find ways to fight
the system whenever we can.
- Wait, hold on.
- Here.
What the?
Hello? Mom.
- [Voiceover] Can you hear me?
- Yes, could you flip the phone around?
I can't hear you.
- [Voiceover] Hello? Milo?
- You're speaking into the earpiece.
You need to be speaking
into the mouthpiece
so flip the phone.
- I didn't know she uses walnut?
Milo, could you ask your
mom about the cookie recipe?
- Shut up. Yes I will.
Mom, question, this necklace thing.
I really like the one you
sent but it's just not the
one I actually wanted to wear.
- [Voiceover] I know it's
not the one you wanted
but this one is from
your great grandmother
and she'd be happy to see you wear it.
It's nice.
- Yeah I know, it's very nice.
I'm not saying it's not nice.
It's just that I was
going for a certain look.
- What is this?
- [Voiceover] A certain look?
- Is this cinnamon?
- [Voiceover] Are you eating?
- [Milo] Yes mom, I am eating.
That is such a weird question.
Please stop asking that.
I love you, I'll talk to you later, bye.
- I wonder if I can
replicate this formula?
Did you hang up?
- Yes, Paul.
- Without getting the recipe?
(Milo groans)
Now I have to call her back.
Gimme the phone.
- [Milo] Will you stop it.
- Attitude.
Okay. I need to get my
hand on these recipes
for these cookies.
Trying to ask you is pointless,
considering you only
know how to make eggs.
You on that damn Tumblr?
- Yes, Paul, I'm on Tumblr.
- Who or what are you looking at?
- Well, Marvel Fandom, Unwanted Nudity,
Inspirational Posts, and Lela White.
- Lela White, Instagram model?
- Well she's not an Instagram
model, she's a real model.
And she's so cool.
I don't know, she's so comfortable
with herself and really
chill and really cool with being nude.
- Yes she is.
- Stop.
- [Paul] Okay.
- She just perfect, and she's super smart.
She reblogged one of my
Bukowski-inspired poems.
- She wearing a little too
much make-up if you ask me.
- She just wants to be
flawless in pictures.
Nothing wrong with that.
- You know who has flawless skin?
- Who?
- What's the letter after
'T' in the alphabet?
- 'U'?
- Me?
No not me, you.
You're the letter, the letter 'U', baby.
- Oh. I see, what you did there.
- [Paul] Yeah.
- Okay, no, not your best.
- I know.
- Well, I have to get ready.
I'm going to a party where BW is spinning
and Lela White will be there.
So we're gonna meet each other
and be best friends and
travel the world together.
It'll be great.
- [Paul] Alright, good luck with that.
- Where's my phone?
What are you doing with my phone?
- Calling your mom.
- Paul!
- Hello Mrs. Wright, how you doing?
- [Voiceover] Who is this?
- Okay, alright, now about those cookies.
- [Voiceover] No Paul, I'm not
giving you my cookie recipe.
(electronic club music)
- Milo!
- [Milo] Hey.
- You made it.
- [Milo] Ya.
- Hi!
- [Milo] Hi BW.
- Thank you so much for
coming out and supporting me.
- [Milo] No problem, I came to see you.
- Get ready to see some
new moves I learned in the
DJ Academy.
- Okay.
Hey BW real quick.
- [BW] Yeah?
- How do I look?
- Milo, you are but a queen amongst us.
And I just really think that--
- Yo, play 'Shake dat ass', Trick!
- Duty calls.
(giggles)
- Okay well listen, you kill it, have fun.
I think I see somebody I know,
so I just wanted to go say 'hi', okay?
- [BW] Yeah.
- Alright, bye. Have fun.
- [BW] Alright, see you later.
- [Milo] See ya.
(electronic club music)
- Hey, Lela?
- Hi.
- [Milo] Hi.
- Do I know you?
- Yeah, I'm Milo, we follow
each other on Tumblr.
- Oh, yeah, I recognize you.
- [Milo] Yeah.
- You're the one that writes
all those really weird
poems about death.
- Oh, I mean, well, they're
not about death per se,
they're kind of subjective,
they could be about life.
Yeah, but they're all
Charles Bukowski themed.
- Who, Bu-what-ee, wait.
(giggles)
- Charles Bukowski?
I thought you knew him,
since you've reblogged
a couple of his poems.
- No, I don't know him.
I literally just reblog
whatever looks good on the page.
Like, I don't even know where
half that stuff comes from.
- Oh.
- [Lela] Yeah.
- Okay.
(slow easy music)
- What is that?
What are you?
Come on!
- Quick question.
- [Milo] Yeah.
- Do you have any Coke?
- Like Coca Cola?
- No, like blow, like cocaine, like
(sniffs)
- No no no, I don't do cocaine.
- No worries, it's cool.
Maria, honey, can you please
go and find me some Coke?
- [Maria] Yes I gotcha on that.
- Thank you so much, I love you.
Thank you thank you thank you.
(hip hop music)
- What?
Mint.
- Yes, so, can I do anything for you?
You wanna take a selfie?
You wanna like, chill?
- Yeah, I'll take a selfie,
let's take a selfie.
- [Lela] Okay sounds good.
- Yeah.
Wait, sorry, phone's a little broke.
Really nice necklace by the way.
- Aw thank you.
The company is paying me to wear it.
- [Milo] Okay.
(camera clicks)
Nice to meet you.
- It was nice to meet you too.
Bye Mee-low.
- It's Milo.
- Okay, Mee-low, great.
So do you know who Charles Bukowski is?
He sounds super hot.
(slow bluesy guitar)
- Hey.
- [Paul] Hey!
- What's up?
- I found out what was in these cookies.
- Oh yeah, what?
- It's mint.
A hint of mint.
- Yeah I could have told you that.
Forgot she had a garden.
- What a gem, now I can
make these all the time.
- Yeah, yeah, for sure.
- How was meeting Lela?
- Honestly she was awful.
Yeah, she was kinda mean.
And not that smart.
- Awe.
- Yeah.
- I'm sorry puddin'.
- It's okay.
- I know what it's like to
find out your hero's a dud.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
It's like at my fourth
birthday party when I took off
Spiderman's mask and it was
really just my Aunt Lisa
in a bald cap.
Those situations can be
disappointing and very confusing.
- Yeah, I guess.
But you know what?
She wasn't even a hero to me.
She wasn't like Condelezza
Rice or Will Smith.
I just thought she'd be a nice friend.
Somebody I could kick it with, for once.
Besides you guys of course.
Wanna see a selfie?
- [Paul] Yeah.
- Alright, you're going to barf.
- You know if someone asked
me who'd I wanna hang out with
based on this very real, unplanned,
un-Photoshopped picture,
it would definitely be you.
- Awww.
- You're the cool one.
You're the real one.
Home grown in Philly with just
a little dash of something
special that's hard to figure out.
You are your mom's cookies.
- Thank you.
- And they are so tasty.
You want some girl?
- No thank you.
- They're delicious.
- No, I'm good.
♫ Tasty Mama's cookies
♫ Put 'em in a box, hey
♫ Tasty Mama's cookies ♫
- [Milo] Can you stop singing?
♫ Get 'em while they're hot ♫
- [ Milo] That sounds
really inappropriate.
♫ Taste your mama's cookies
♫ Your mom's cookies taste really good ♫
- Stop.
That's a really inappropriate song.
- What show is this?
- [Voiceover] Don't crap on my front porch
and tell me it's a mud pie.
- Okay, I'm in.
♫ Taste your mama's cookies
♫ Put 'em in a box
♫ Get 'em while they're hot
♫ Tasty's mama's cookies
♫ They came with a note
♫ Eat 'em in a boat ♫